we're gonna begin with news affecting
all of us at this broadcast and this
network CBS News has suspended our
co-host Charlie Rose over allegations of
sexual misconduct The Washington Post is
you have heard published claims from
eight women who all worked or wanted to
work for his PBS program and they
described Rose making unwanted sexual
advantage advances rather in the 1990s
through 2011 bianna golodryga is here
with the allegations and Charlie's
response to them be on a good morning
Gail good morning this one does hit
close to home we've been able to reach
out to one of those accusers she didn't
want to go on camera but confirms that
the reporting is accurate additional
women have since spoken out to Business
Insider and The New York Times
some say he groped them or exposed
himself to them and many paint a picture
of a respected figure abusing his
position I think that you can't
understate you know the level of
influence and power that a man like
Charlie Rose has Washington Post
reporter Amy Britton spent weeks
reaching out to roses former employees
and job seekers several described Rose
putting his hand on their legs sometimes
their upper thigh one said he groped her
breasts as she drove him in a car two
women said he walked naked in front of
them after taking a shower
some critics might say well why were
they in the position you know to to see
him naked but the thing about Charlie
Rose is that he would commonly require
his employees to come over to his
private homes he allegedly invited one
woman to his home on Long Island while
considering her for a job
she described crying the entire time as
he reached down her pants Rose tweeted a
statement yesterday evening saying I
deeply apologize for my inappropriate
behavior I am greatly embarrassed I have
behaved in sensitively at times and I
accept responsibility for that though I
do not believe that all of these
allegations are accurate Rose explained
I always felt that I was pursuing shared
feelings even though I now realize I was
mistaken this is the CBS News Nightwatch
good morning during a long career in
journalism Rose earned multiple Emmys
and a Peabody Award this but it's his
signature interview program that made
him a household name in 2014 he was one
of Time Magazine's 100 most influential
people in the world
he has such power over the show he owns
the show there is no human resources
department and the Charlie Rose show
many of these women said that even if
they wanted to file an official
complaint they wouldn't even know who to
go to one of the accusers former
assistant Kyle Godfrey Ryan said in a
Facebook post at the work environment at
the Charlie Rose show supported a
spectrum of misconduct from unhealthy
boundaries to outright physical abuse
she's one of two women who told The
Washington Post they reported roses
behavior to the show's executive
producer Yvette Vega
she claims Vega would shrug and just say
that's just Charlie being Charlie in a
statement to the post Vega wrote I
should have stood up for them I failed
it is crushing I deeply regret not
helping them the Charlie Rose program
airs on PBS and then rears on Bloomberg
both networks have suspended the program
Charlie Rose has co-hosted this
broadcast since its debut in 2012 he's
also a contributing correspondent to 60
minutes in a statement CBS News says
he's suspended immediately while we look
into the matter these allegations are
extremely disturbing and we take them
very seriously the Washington Post
reporter told us more than a dozen other
women have reached out wanting to speak
or share their stories since this
article appeared yesterday and Norah as
as tough as the story is it's important
that we cover it the same way we covered
the other ones
well said bianna thank you and yeah I
know you and I had talked a lot about
this it takes a lot of courage for these
women to come forward and I think that
they should continue to do something to
do that they will continue to speak up
yeah I also want to say this that this
is a moment that demands a frank and
honest assessment about where we stand
and more generally the safety of women
let me be very clear there is no excuse
for this alleged behavior it is
systematic and pervasive and I've been
doing a lot of listening and I'm going
to continue to do that this I know is
true women cannot achieve equality in
the workplace or in society until there
is a reckoning and a taking of
responsibility I'm really proud to work
at CBS News there are so many incredible
people here especially on this show all
of you here this will be investigated
this has to end this behavior is wrong
period
I certainly echo that and I I have to
say no I really am still reeling I got
an hour and 42 minutes to sleep last
night both my son and my daughter called
me Oprah called me and said are you okay
I am NOT okay after reading that article
in the post it was deeply disturbing
troubling and painful for me to read
that said I think we have to make this
matter to women the women that it was
spoken up the women who have not spoken
up because they were afraid I'm hoping
that now they will take the step to
speak out to that this becomes a moment
of truth
you know I've enjoyed a friendship and a
partnership with Charlie for the past
five years I've held him in such high
regard and I'm really struggling because
how do you what do you say when someone
that you deeply care about has done
something that is so horrible how do you
wrap your brain around that I'm really
grappling with that that said Charlie
does not get a pass here he doesn't get
a pass from anyone in this room we were
all deeply affected we are all rocked by
this and I I want to echo what Nora said
I really applaud the women that speak up
despite the friendship he doesn't get a
pass because I can't stop thinking about
the anguish of these women what happened
to their dignity what happened to their
bodies what happened maybe to even their
careers I can't stop thinking about that
in the pain that they're going through I
also find that it's you can hold two
ideas in your head at the same time you
can grapple with things and I to be very
honest with you I'm still trying to
process all
I'm still trying to sort it out because
this is not the man I know but I'm also
clearly on the side of the women who
have been very hurt and very damaged by
this and I'm gonna you know I haven't
spoken to him have you spoken to him I
haven't spoken to him I intend to speak
to him certainly later today when I'm
very sorry and I'm very glad that they
have spoken up I said we are gonna
continue to do our reporting on this
story and other allegations that have
come forward and we're gonna continue I
just say this or we have a great team
here and we're all as you said very
committed to bringing you the news even
when it affects us so deeply none of us
ever thought that we'd be sitting at
this table in particular telling this
story but here we are but we will
continue to report the news as we always
have